Друзі, всім привіт!
У коментарях до серії про будівництво приватних будинків у Німеччині
ви запропонували показати технологію Смарт-Хоум.
Як це відбувається у німців, пропоную спочатку подивитися
старого, переобладнаного будинку.
До речі, цьому будинку 130 років.
Ходімо всередину.
Мене зустрічають спеціаліст зі встановлення систем "розумних" будинків Борис Рупнік
і дизайнерка інтер’єрів та художниця
Урсула Кольманн.
Вона повністю розробила дизайн цього будинку.
Спочатку жодних розумних технологій і не помічаєш,
однак поступово усвідомлюєш,
що вони тут скрізь.
Це не просто планшет, це - пристрій дистанційного керування
системою "розумного" будинку.
Незалежно від того, хто виробник того чи іншого пристрою в будинку,
ми інтегруємо його, щоб управляти ним якомога простіше з цього планшета.
Геніальність у тому, що в кожній кімнаті
ми можемо моніторити ті пристрої, які саме активовані.
Наприклад, серед опцій "дивитися", "слухати",
"освітлення" обираємо останню і можемо змінитиатмосферу.
Друзі, коли я увійшов у будинок,
я подумав, що це картина з підсвіткою.
Насправді це мультимедійна система.
Дивіться, а ось це не просто зебра-декор.
Тут заховані динаміки.
На цьому сюрпризи зі звуком не закінчуються.
Друзі, а ще в цій розумній системі є ефект голосу Бога – послухайте.
Звук іде згори.
Налаштувавши світло, активуємо опцію "кіно".
Повертаюся в меню управління у розділ "Дивитися",
і тут можна вибрати  різні джерела.
Активуємо, наприклад, зараз телевізор.
Звичайно, можна вибрати і інші джерела, наприклад ДіВіДі-плеєр.
Можна синхронізувати планшет для керування "розумним" будинком
зі смартфоном або комп’ютером через блютус
і здійснювати всі операції дистанційно.
Наприклад, закривання жалюзі,
відкривати фіранки
або електронний замок вхідних дверей.
Загалом  капітальний ремонт із заміною усіх комунікацій
і встановленням смарт-системи
обійшовся у цьому будинку у 200 тисяч євро.
Утім, без капітальних перебудов просту смарт-систему
у ФРН можна встановити і за кілька тисяч євро.
Цей будинок робить унікальним не лише його розумність,
але й дизайн інтер’єру.
Оскільки будинок слугує своєрідним зразком
для потенційних клієнтів,
у ньому зібрані усі тренди
в кольорах і матеріалах, які наразі є затребуваними у німців.
І як гадаєте, що замовляють разом
з приладами "розумного" будинку?
Штукатурку з натуральних еко-матеріалів і жодного гіпсокартону!
Техніка штукатурки забезпечує легку структуру.
Ми працюємо лише зі 100-відсотково мінеральними матеріалами,
які не є шкідливими для здоров'я.
Жодного мікропластику
чи пластмаси у помешканні.
Лише традиційні і високоякісні матеріали.
Тут, наприклад, у нас вапняна штукатурка,
однак вона нанесена двічі і додатково вкрита металічним воском,
тому поверхня приємна на дотик
і чудово виглядає.
Як на мене, найсміливіші ідеї Урсула Кольманн,
яка є маляркою з 25-річним стажем,
втілила у туалетних кімнатах.
Тут ми випробували дуже актуальну тематику джунглів.
Верхня частина стін обклеєна шпалерами -  темна і загадкова атмосфера.
Знизу основа з французької мінеральної штукатурки.
Ми облаштовуємо ванні кімнати без плитки.
У Німеччині це називається безшовною технологією.
Натомість використовується або водонепроникна штукатурка,
або, як отут, водостійкі шпалери.
Тим, кому смарт-технологій замало і хочеться ще й коштовних витребеньок,
Урсула Кольманн пропонує особливо екстравагантний дизайн - золоті стіни.
І це не просто фарба, як мені спочатку здалося…
Ця позолота з платиновим відтінком, а ця - з мідним.
Можна вибрати те, що підходить.
Це справжнє сухозлітне золото,
24 карата.
На цій стіні один квадратний метр коштує 500 євро.
Далі з Борисом Рупніком їдемо на інший берег Рейну у район Бонна - Бойль.
Тут розташований окремий павільйон
з системами безпеки для "розумного" будинку.
Це датчик який запускає в будинок за відбитком пальця.
Ось так.
Замок активований - можна відкривати.
Ось така особливість тут.
А що ж робити, якщо в будинку вимкнеться електрика?
Для цього у кожному з цих приладів стоять батареї,
які гарантують вхід і вихід з будинку
протягом трьох діб.
На цій стіні - десятки варіантів датчиків для сканування пальців і сенсорних вимикачів.
Усі вони виготовлені з металу.
Звичайно, є і датчики для допуску в приміщення за пластиковою карткою.
Зараз у багатьох сучасних домофонах є можливість інтегрувати відеокамеру.
Борис Рупнік пояснює в чому перевага
смарт-домофонів.
Дзвінок активує стаціонарний дисплей, через який можна комунікувати
і бачити того, хто прийшов.
Можна налаштувати доступ через смартфон.
Тут не лише домофон, а й вся система безпеки.
Я можу увійти і миттєво побачити зображення з камер спостереження будинку.
У системі завжди є другий переносний пристрій.
Через нього я теж можу спілкуватися з відео.
Ідея – один планшет для управління усім дистанційно.
Завдяки мобільному додатку можна віддалено зайти до системи "розумного" будинку.
От, наприклад, у мене є можливість керувати температурою опалення на відстані,
коли мене немає вдома.
Зараз знижую температуру.
Зі смартфона також можна ставити дім на сигналізацію.
Це єдина система з датчиків руху, камер спостереження і датчиків відкривання дверей.
Ось так виглядає кімната смарт-будинку.
Звичайна собі кімната, яку видають лише багатофункціональні дисплеї
на стінах і сенсорні вимикачі.
Критики смарт хоум зауважують,
що програма може зависати і тоді користувач втрачає час на перезавантаження.
В гіршому випадку, якщо не буде електрики і водночас сядуть резервні батареї,
не відкриються жалюзі або вхідний замок.
Системи розумного будинку – унікальні та ізольовані
і не відомо чи будуть продаватися програмні оновлення до них у майбутньому.
Також хмарні технології не працюють без інтернета,
а сервери фірм-виробників  розумної системиможуть бути вразливими для зламу.
Виробникам ще є над чим працювати.
Далі їдемо до павільйону, де показані можливості інтер’єру смарт-будинків.
Ну що ж, - я приїхав у Кельн подивитися, як працюють "розумні" меблі.
Ходімо - випробуємо!
Друзі, смарт-меблі в дії.
Ось так відкриваються шафи.
І дуже легко закриваються.
А стіл дуже легко із барної висоти
трансформується у висоту обіднього столу.
Борис Рупнік як спеціаліст із мультимедійних систем
демонструє концепт прихованої техніки.
Телевізор захований у стіні і стає доступним, коли піднімається ширма.
Також окремо можна керувати появою жовтого міні-бару.
Тепер ширма з телевізором закривається
і зі стелі спускається екран для кінопроекторів.
Друзі, а найбільше мені подобається ось ця кнопочка.
А в комплекті до смарт-технологій іде ось такий-от порепаний стіл.
Подивіться, якої глибини тріщини.
У Німеччині смарт-технології ще раніше, ніж у приватних будинках,
почали використовувати у громадському просторі.
Друзі, я перебуваю в районі Бонна Нордшдадт.
З іншого боку дороги за нами спостерігає художник-експресіоніст Август Маке,
який жив у цьому будинку понад 100 років тому.
Тепер тут його будинок-музей, в якому втілені багато смарт-технологій.
Керівник будівництва музею, яке обійшлося у 8 мільйонів євро,
Гельмут Лауфер проводить на дах, з якого можна оцінити
масштаб добудови нового комплексу до будинку, де жив художник.
Ми на даху розширеного Музею Августа Маке.
Ось там, навпроти, стара будівля.
Вона була розширена за допомогою ось тієї вузької будівлі,
яка переходить до цієї більшої будівлі.
Всі найновітніші смарт-технології, які можуть бути корисні у музейній справі,
втілили саме у новій добудованій частині.
Відвідувач, заходячи до виставкової зали, щоправда,
жодних високотехнологічних приладів не помічає. Все заховано.
Через велику кількість маленьких дірочок у стелі
у виставковий зал подається повітря, яке пройшло через систему кондиціонування.
Температура повітря тут завжди 20 градусів, вологість – 50%.
А потім відпрацьоване повітря
ось через ці отвори втягується у систему.
Підтримка постійного мікроклімату у виставковій залі
дозволяє зберігати витвори мистецтва
в ідеальному стані.
Я навіть і гадки не мав, який масштаб цієї розумної системи.
Вся вона захована у підвалі будівлі.
Друзі, ви тільки гляньте!
Наче це не підвал музею, а міжнародна космічна станція.
Коли ми побудували цей підземний поверх,
він був таким великим, як собор.
Я тоді подумав, чи зможемо ми його колись заповнити технічними приладами.
Тепер цей величезний зал заповнений вщент.
Тут повітря не лише зволожується паром, підігрівається або охолоджується,
а ще й проходить кілька стадій очищення.
Тут же - центр управління протипожежною системою.
Звідси здійснюється постійний зв’язок з пожежною станцією.
Весь музей оснащений детекторами диму.
Тож приїзд вогнеборців прорахований у межах від 5 до 10 хвилин.
В запасниках  музею також підтримується свій мікроклімат.
Унікальним є внутрішній садок, де любив гуляти художник
Його відгородили від шуму дороги скляною стіною висотою із сам музей.
Директорка Клара Дренкер-Нагельс проводить до культового місця,
яке найбільше приваблює відвідувачів.
Тут, на третьому поверсі старого будинку, розташована майстерня,
де творив Август Маке.
А у старій будівлі, де жив і творив художник,
чиї картини розійшлися по галереях усього світу,
проекція цих робіт на стіну повертає їх до місця народження.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях,
що ще ви хотіли б дізнатися про Німеччину,
і я обов’язково про це розповім у одній з наступних серій.
Щасти вам!